today eduardo trying to go to
four-and-oh before departing for new
york the left-hander rodriguez ready for
the first one against hannigan they've
been swinging very early
gets it past the diving devers base hit
good start for the mariners and going to
stretch it
and we'll get in there for a double
nicely done by mitch haniger here's ty
france
and har net pass it diving divers again
and jd martinez will track it down
henniger's going to score easily
and here's ty france back to back
doubles to open up this game one-nothing
mariners
rbi number 13 for ty is eighth double
for mitch that's his seventh double so
this is a wonderful start france off
third
swing and a miss he struck him out
he keeps them to one run red sox coming
up here against the mariners
nick mark evages will make his third
start of the year pitched out of the
bullpen a couple times but his third
start so far as a starter 0-1 with a 5-4
era the 3-1
that is ball four and they're all loaded
up brings up vazquez 276 with six home
runs as he will take a line driving to
right field that will drop down for a
base hit
kk hernandez
will race on in to score as he dives in
and the red sox have tied it up good
hitting by vazquez take that ball the
other way base is loaded not trying to
do too much with it take the line drive
to the opposite field get a run home and
vazquez filling them up the 3-1 pitch
and walked him and that's going to bring
in a run
boys walk three men
and the red sox about to take a two to
one lead three and two on gonzalez
and he did down into the dirt that'll
force in another run so he's walked in a
couple
red sox being very very patient
and it is three to one and here comes
scott yeah i believe it 32 pitch is
going to make a change here in the first
you can see the frustration for
margavitches after that last ball thrown
in the dirt
1-2
inside and got him that hit him
he's in some pain though arroyo gets
drilled and another run is in but he's
in serious pain
gets his fourth rbi the hard way
for sure i think he's gonna stay in
taking his base so four walks a hit
batsman and two singles in this inning
bases remain loaded
double play
it's a p
for france
to white that'll do it nine men to the
plate 4-1 red sox
wave and a miss 86 miles an hour to
strike him out found that change up
right there good movement on it moving
down and away
that's in there for strike three
so he comes back nicely gets the next
three after the lead off double zander
struck out in first
line drive sucked down into the corner
he connected on that one
hernandez is in
and
denver's went too far around third he's
trying to get back partner rundown red
sox get a 5-1 lead
and he is going to be out
and all the way down to third
is xander bogarts
i don't know what ravi was doing coming
around third base but uh there's the
ball down the left field line and i mean
no problem here for inanes come around
and score now they're trying to hold him
up he's trying to hold him up right
there but he couldn't stop in time so
they get him caught in the run down then
the one thing he does well he stays in
the rundown and he gets bogots an extra
base at third three balls two strikes
trying to put away the lead off man in
the inning and he sits him down he
struck him out looking perfect pitch
breaking ball right on the outside part
of the play just completely froze
kyle lewis yeah i don't know if that was
a cutter or a slider but something
in one of the two or something in
between how's that to cover it
a big swing and a miss
and down goes white
it just goes to show you you know you
don't have to be overpowering to get
strikeouts and you know eddie's not
overpowering this afternoon 91 miles an
hour but he's putting the ball at the
top of the strike zone to get a lot of
those strikeouts with the fastball
so one on here's catcher tom murphy
swang in a hard hit ground ball down the
third base line a fair ball pass to
diving denver's down the left-field line
and toward the corner hagerty rounding
third he's going to score up with the
ball is martinez the throw-in is cut off
by the shortstop gonzalez tom murphy and
it's second base with a smile on his
face an rbi double
and it's now the red sox five of the
mariners two
so the mariners cut the lead with the
single by hagerty and now the double by
tom murphy right over the bag at third
and down the left field line all the way
into the corner and murphy picks up his
second run bad and end this year
3-2 to jp
high target
hold it and it's fairs against by
dalbeck
off the sidewall murphy will score
here come the mariners rbi double j p
crawford got a 5-3 ball game here in the
fifth bottom third of the order to face
l.j newsome or lj the second inning of
work
swinging in a miss
second strikeout lj newsome second and
last three hitters
it's a right field
dylan moore right there lj newsom fine
fine work
and his 1-2 pitch swing and a miss he
put away another one well he's he's got
that down today i mean he's got you know
as i've said many times it's not
overpowering it's 91 but it's the
location of these high fastballs that
they continue
to chase i mean that's that's shoulder
high shoulder high and a season high
eight k's three two
and a liner caught by the leaping
gonzales in a nice play
to retire the side eddie rodriguez
through seven tai france one for three a
double he's also struck out two times
and a bounty ball charged by gonzalez
flips out of the glove got an out on
defense
oh is that beautiful absolutely gorgeous
gonzalez to arroyo to dolbeck for two
beautiful thing beautiful thing nice
little flip out of the glove i didn't
think they were gonna have a chance for
a double play the way the ball was hit
but look at that backhanded right to the
lettuce on arroyo and all he's going to
do is throw the first base
that was sweet by gonzalez
up the middle of j.p crawford pirouette
oh that's a heck of a play great stretch
by white nice job bill miller said yep
they had the base fine play both ends jp
showing the range up the middle the
delivery super mow the spin and throw
gets get rid of it quickly and let your
first baseman do
the rest of the work and why not that
barnes looking to protect the two-run
advantage matt last time out finally
gave up some runs and a two-two coming
oh dandy 97
to strike him out one gone a nice fast
ball outside part of the plate adevino
had a strikeout to end the eighth bonds
to start the ninth nobody on base two
down and matt barnes fires
in there at 98 to strike him out and end
the ball game so the red sox win it
5-3 the final today over seattle
allowing the mariners only six hits sox
had just five but they got those runs
early
and made him count eduardo rodriguez
gets the win he's now 4
and 0 on the season